I wish real life had built in like and
dislike buttons the way YouTube does i'd
upload all the cute cats I see and I
downvote the hell out of the new social
media scarefest unfriended the second
couple more I explain why on this week's
episode of angry nerd first your
comments smart games asks can you talk
about futurama and why it was cancelled
smart games check out my future on the
episode from 2013 I'm glad that futurama
got cancelled again phantom 9250 to
rights I hate the idea of making
Fantastic Four into teenagers how can
they be exploring the cosmos if they're
worried about next week's chemistry
final I know right I also worry that
Doctor Doom will escape will they fight
over which group selfie to post to
Instagram Ben you are totally covering
my face in this one I will fire blast
you if you post that speaking of teens
ruining movies unfriended is about six
high school kids who cyberbully another
student to death and are tormented by
her ghost fine except that action plays
out on social media feeds thrillingly
shifting between skype chats facebook
friends youtube clips I messages the
screen capture format isn't unique it
also cropped up in open windows
disconnect you want me to kill him the
den even an episode of modern family but
I still find it to be a profoundly
depressing twist on the found-footage
genre horror and voyeurism are old
friends but character POV only works if
the terror feels plausible watching
video group chats complete with glitchy
buffering effects takes you completely
out of the moment instead of being
immersed in fear you just feel like
you're you're peeking over your
co-workers shoulder well he shows you a
funny video he just failed don't you
hate that anyway I worry that if
unfriended is a hit it will make horror
directors even more lazy they don't even
have to follow around a bunch of unknown
actors with a handheld camera anymore
they just have to buy a video capture
card and voila an exciting shot of a
computer desktop and
they just invent some drama like like
like oh oh great heavens my spreadsheet
was deleted and some evil spirit has
disabled automatic backup ooh scary how
do they wait that the catalogue of my
comic book collection hey that's not
cool don't even joke about that getting
deleted ooh ooh hoping there's been some
mistake clearly that ridiculous child's
toys not meant for me how do i click on
this and make it go away oh oh that
that's not mine either ah oh Jesus how
do i turn the screen off hey I take it
all back a direct feed of your desktop
can be nightmarish actually it's easy to
find horrifying spectacles and jump
scares on your desktop computer you just
click over to chatroulette ah oh how do
you say put some pants on in Hungarian
but seriously how much more lazy can a
filmmaker possibly get what will they
make a movie about a haunted autocorrect
feature that turns all of your text
messages into profanity hope that
doesn't give anyone any bright ideas
seriously can you think of any movies
that have done a good job of showing how
people actually use technology to help
themselves in scary situations let me
know in the comments you should also
subscribe to the wire channel and click
on these miniature versions of me to
watch my other magnificent fitting Oh
hold on getting a text message from one
of these other versions of me it says
don't go see Jupiter ascending it's not
very good I know that now you're
supposed to send their backwards in time
yeah yachts ah